[Música]
y
franco tiene 5 años es un niño travieso
le encanta jugar fútbol su posición
favorita es de arquero cuando está
aburrido en casa le gusta agarrar la
guitarra de su papá y ponerse a tocar el
cantar la canción de josé luis perales
que canten los niños una hermosa canción
que aprendió en el coro de su kinder
franco es mi hijo es el mayor de 3
el único varón y nació con síndrome de
dawn
alguien de ustedes se imaginó en algún
momento que describía las cualidades de
un niño con síndrome de dawn
hemos crecido creyendo que las personas
con síndrome de dawn
son esos niños eternos huesos angelitos
que solamente vienen a dar amor a sus
padres
o por otro lado son esos pobres niños
enfermos que no pueden aprender y ni
hablar
al menos eso era lo que yo pensaba
cuando me dieron la noticia que mi hijo
nació con esta condición
sentí muchísimo miedo
miedo de que iba a ser de la vida de mío
miedo de como mi vida iba a cambiar
el convertirnos en padre cambia nuestra
vida por completo es un nuevo desafío
que afrontamos mayor responsabilidad
tener un hijo con discapacidad no me
hace ser una mamá especial ni diferente
tengo el mismo deber y responsabilidad
de sacar adelante a mi hijo y
convertirlo en la mejor versión de él
una vez esto se puede entender con la
mente y con el corazón todo se vuelve
mucho más fácil
para hablar de la inclusión de las
personas con síndrome de dawn en nuestra
sociedad primeramente debemos hablar de
la inclusión en el hogar
cada hijo es un mundo que gira alrededor
de las expectativas de su propia familia
el día de hoy quiero compartirles tres
pilares muy importantes que me han
servido para llevar la crianza no
solamente de francos sino también de
camila y olivia mis otras dos hijas
número 1 educarme como mamá
número 2 creer en mis hijos y su
incapacidad
y número 3 prepararlos para su
importancia
educarme ha sido el arma más poderosa
que me ayudó a salir del desconocimiento
y de la ignorancia en este afán de
buscar respuestas a todas las preguntas
que tenían comenzó fue a vivir un ciclo
de aprendizaje en donde conocí muchas
familias asistí a cursos talleres hasta
congresos internacionales que me
cambiaron por completo la mirada del
síndrome de down de haber sido en un
inicio un problema me convirtió a un
retenido
educarme me permitió entender que mi
hijo no es ningún niño enfermo que no
sufre por su condición que no necesito
curarlo ni repararlo para aceptarlo como
él
educarme me permitió entender que mi
hijo no es menos que nadie tiene el
mismo valor y la misma importancia y
derechos que cualquiera de nosotros a
que pueda acceder a un plan de salud que
pueda estudiar en un colegio regular y
no segregado que más adelante puede
estudiar una carrera profesional y ser
una persona que aporte también a la
sociedad
como madre es mi deber de extender cada
uno de sus derechos
educarme me permitió sentirme bien
conmigo misma que no fue mi culpa de no
haberme cuidado en el embarazo esto es
algo que sucede al azar 1 cada 600
nacimientos y en el mundo existen más de
8 millones de personas con síndrome de
dawn
educar me permitió también enseñar a
otras personas que mi hijo puede
aprender
y aprenderá todo lo que nosotros
decidamos enseñarle lo único que
necesita son oportunidades
y las oportunidades podemos darles todos
los frutos
el segundo pilar que quiero compartirles
se trata sobre creer en místicos y sus
capacidades
para construir algo primeramente debemos
creer que es posible porque si yo no
creo que fue difícil que pueda construir
alguien
una vez una mamá me dijo con los ojos
que veas a tu hijo llorando escojo con
el mundo
no puedo esperar que la sociedad cree en
mismo y primeramente yo no creo en él
la inclusión comienza en casa
franco es un niño que lo hemos incluido
desde que nació sin diferencias lo
tratamos exactamente igual que a sus
hermanas
nos ayuda a acomodar la mesa a ordenar
la casa a guardar sus juguetes incluso
lo desafiamos a hacer más cosas porque
entendemos que tienen retos pero con
mucho amor constancia repetición en
logra alcanzar cada uno de los objetivos
creer en unas trocitos es un valor tan
importante para poder desarrollar su
autonomía que debemos aprender a confiar
para educar
a continuación quiero contarles la
siguiente historia
en la búsqueda de encontrar un colegio
una amiga me comentó que había un nuevo
colegio que te estaba abriendo a los
pasos hacia la inflación cuando voy a
este lugar
la secretaria me recibe y me indica que
la psicóloga del colegio era la persona
responsable de hacer las entrevistas a
los padres para mi suerte ese día ya se
encontraba disponible así que me llevó
hasta la oficina cuando llegue la
psicóloga se encontraba en una llamada
telefónica era una mujer joven delgada
pelo castaño contaba con unos delicados
anteojos ella al percatarse de mi
presencia extendió su brazo indicando
bien que tomar asiento
cuando me senté fue inevitable ver esa
pared gris que había detrás de ella
donde habían muchos cuadros colgados de
cursos talleres certificaciones que
tenía esta psicóloga me llamó la
atención este deseo de prepararse en su
área profesional
cuando colgó el teléfono me miró y me
dijo buenos días en que puedo ayudarle
buenos días estoy buscando una plaza
para mi hijo él tiene 5 años le toca
cursar primero básico y nació con
síndrome down
nunca voy a olvidar
el dow firmamento
destacó el ambiente y me dijo
porque seas complicará tu ido villa para
en todo en la vida será difícil de
aprender
hemos crecido segregado de la diversidad
y de entender el valor de la inclusión
ningún curso ningún taller nos enseñará
más que la propia experiencia de dar la
oportunidad de conocer para entender
esta historia que les acabo de contar es
una historia real
en una historia que le sucedió a otro
mono
una historia que me marcó
desde el fin en este lugar
todavía existen muchas personas que
niegan las oportunidades a nuestros
hijos por creer que no pueden
solamente reconocen limitaciones en vez
de abriendo cambiar su mirada y podrás
reconocer y valorar su capacidad
es más fácil decir nos estamos
preparados que asumir nuestra
responsabilidad como ciudadanos
de incluir a todos por igual
así como existen puertas que se nos
cierran también existen puertas que se
nos abren en donde nuestros hijos
tendrán la oportunidad de aprender en el
campo de francos es un niño que desde
los 6 meses fue incluido en un jardín
infantil
es rodearse con otros niños le permitió
desarrollar muchas habilidades de manera
natural como es por medio de la
invitación
el año pasado de graduado de un kínder
con muchos logros con muchos
reconocimientos de sus maestros una
mención especial del profesor de inglés
que esto es terco y me dijo que es
franco se destacaba entre los mejores
alumnos múltiples
este año tenemos un gran desafío con
francos le toca a cortar primero básico
en un colegio bilingüe
estamos seguros que le irá muy bien
porque creemos en él porque estamos en
el lugar indicado con las personas
indicadas que juntos vamos a construir
la mejor versión de él
el tercer pilar que quiero contarles es
sobre prepararlos para la ineficiencia
no ayudamos a nuestros hijos a crecer ya
madurar si hacemos las cosas por ellos
ayudamos a crecer ya madurar cuando
posibilitamos que hagan las cosas por sí
solos
el ser humano por naturaleza ya es un
ser sobreprotector si ustedes recuerdan
cuando eran niños como nuestros padres
nos sobreprotegía portamos a todos
y muchas veces esta sobreprotección ha
repercutido en nuestra vida cuando somos
inseguros cuando necesitamos la
aceptación de otra persona
para desarrollar la independencia
tenemos que aprender a educar en
libertad
libertad que nuestros hijos tomen sus
propias decisiones que elijan decida sí
que nosotros tengamos que imponerles
todo el tiempo
franco es un niño que a su corta edad
nos ha demostrado muchas habilidades de
independencia y autonomía es un niño que
come solo una vez que termina de comer
lleva su plato de comida a la cocina le
encanta elegir la ropa que se va a poner
si se imaginaran esas combinaciones que
tienen
pero eso es otro tema aquí no se trata
si él eligió bien si combinó bien si
tomó buenas decisiones uno aquí se trata
que le estamos dando a ese espacio para
quien pueda desarrollar esas habilidades
y que asuma el control de su vida para
que en un futuro nadie decida por él
el primer paso para lograr eléctrico de
nuestros hijos
comienza en el hogar
educándonos
creyendo a nuestros hijos y prepararlos
para la independencia
tener un hijo siempre estará lo mismo
los límites los ponemos nosotros somos
nosotros quienes construimos el futuro
de nuestros hijos
nosotros deseamos tener hijos exitosos y
yo les pregunto que estamos haciendo
para prepararnos mejor como padres
somos conscientes que nuestros actos
nuestras decisiones repercutirán en la
vida de nuestros hijos
nuestros hijos al final van a hacer lo
que ellos deciden ser en su vida
nuestro deber es acompañarnos en todo
momento y creer siempre que sí se puede
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]